ونتابع في الشان الميداني حيث افادت
السلطات الاوكرانيه في دنياسك بسقوط قتيل
وسبعه جرحى في قصف روسي على مدن عده في
المنطقه وفي غضون ذلك افادت السلطات
المحليه المواليه لروسيا عن سقوط ثلاثه
جرحى في قصف اوكراني استهدف مدينه
جورلوفكا في مقاطعه دونيتسك
تتعرض لقصف يومي بعشرات القذائف والصواريخ
انطلاقا من موقعها الجغرافيه الذي يصل
بخموت بمدينه دونيسك عاصمه المقاطعه
من جارلوك كان شماليه تنضم الينا مراسلتنا
كارمن جوخدار ومن كييف ينضم الينا عدنان
بوريني اهلا بكما نبدا من غور لوفكا
وما يجري هناك
نعم هو قصف يومي ومكثف على هذه المدينه
موقعها الاستراتيجي يمكن القول على هذه
الجبهه وعلى هذا الخط الممتد من بخود
باتجاه دنيتسكت تحاول القوات الاوكرانيه
اختراق هذا الخط عند جورلوفكا بالتحديد
تتكبد هذه المدينه الكثير من الخسائر
البشريه والخسائر حتى في المواقع لديها
وفي البنيه التحتيه حين وصلنا الى جولفكا
اكثر ما يمكن مشاهدته وحجم الدمار الذي
لحقه بعدد من المباني لعل اهم هذه المباني
مستشفيات رصدنا ثلاثه مستشفيات مغلقه
بالكامل بفعل هذا القصف هذا احد
المستشفيات الذي لحق به الدمار واقفل
بالكامل هذا وفق السكان يلقي بثقله على
الاطقم الطبيه التي ما زالت تحاول العمل
في عدد من مراكز
في عدد من المراكز الطبيه هذا الامر ايضا
يتفاقم بفعل عدد الجرح بشكل يومي يسقط
جرحى في جورلوفكا اليوم منذ صبيحه هذا
اليوم ولغايه الان سقط خمسه عشره شخصا
بفعل هذا القصف المستمر ويوم امس كنا في
الصباح في احد الاسواق التي طالها القصف
فجر اليوم السكان واصحاب المحال كانوا
يحاولون احصاء خسائرهم وحتى يحاولون انقاذ
ما يمكن انقاذه من بضائعهم بطبيعه الحال
هذه المدينه منذ بدء الحرب تتعرض لقصف
مكثف ولكن في الاشهر الماضيه عند استعار
المعارك في باخم يتكثف القصف عليها وتتحدث
ويتحدث اهالي هذه المدينه عن اسابيع وايام
داميه بالفعل يوم امس سقط ثلاثه قتلى
وتسعه جرحى في هذا السوق الذي زرناه صبيحه
هذا اليوم هم يتخوفون بطبيعه الحال ان
تشتد المعارك خاصه في ظل المعلومات التي
تكشف عنها اكان القوات الروسيه ووزاره
الدفاع الروسيه عن تكثيف الهجمات الجنوبيه
عليهم قصفا واستهدافات الحياه هنا في
جولفكا صعبه للغايه للوصول الى اي مواد هو
صعب المياه مقطوعه كما جزء كبير من دانيت
في مدينه دانياسك مثلا المياه مقطوعه اذا
يوميات هؤلاء الاشخاص او الاهالي الذين
يعيشون في هذه المدينه صعبه للغايه وهم
يخافون في الايام المقبله من ان يرتد هذا
القصف عليهم المرافق الصحيه قصفت كما
اشرنا ولكن مرافق البنيه التحتيه ايضا يتم
قصفها بشكل مستمر ايضا الاسواق في وسط
مدينه غرفكا التي تبلغ مساحتها اكثر من
400 كلم مربع ايضا تتعرض للقصف والاهالي
يتحدثون عن ايام وحتى اكثر من سنه من
اليوميات المرتبطه بالقصف وحياتهم التي
باتت صعبه للغايه في ظل كل المعارك
المحيطه بهم